So let's think a little
bit about powers of 0.
So what do you think 0 to the
first power is going to be?
And I encourage you
to pause this video.
Well, let's just think about it.
One definition of exponentiation
is that you start with a 1,
and then, you multiply this
number times a 1 one time.
So this is literally
going to be 1 times--
let me do it in the right
color-- it's 1 times 0.
You're multiplying
the 1 by 0 one time.
1 times 0, well, that's
just going to be equal to 0.
Now, what do you think 0
squared or 0 to the second power
is going to be equal to?
Well, once again, one way
of thinking about this
is that you start
with a 1, and we're
going to multiply
it by 0 two times.
So times 0 times 0.
Well, what's that going to be?
Well, you multiply
anything times 0,
once again, you
are going to get 0.
And I think you
see a pattern here.
If I take 0 to any
non-zero number--
so to the power of
any non-zero, so this
is some non-zero number, then
this is going to be equal to 0.
Now, this raises a very
interesting question.
What happens at 0
to the 0-th power?
So here, 0 to the millionth
power is going to be 0.
0 to the trillionth
Even negative or
fractional exponents,
which we haven't
talked about yet,
as long as they're
non-zero, this is just
going to be equal to
0, kind of makes sense.
But now, let's think about
what 0 to the 0-th power
is, because this is actually
a fairly deep question.
And I'll give you a hint.
Well, actually, why
don't you pause the video
and think a little bit about
what 0 to the 0-th power
should be.
Well, there's two
trains of thought here.
You could say, look, 0 to
some non-zero number is 0.
So why don't we just
extend this to all numbers
and say 0 to any
number should be 0.
And so maybe you should say
that 0 to the 0-th power is 0.
But then, there was
another train of logic
that we've already learned,
that any non-zero number,
if you take any non-zero
number, and you raise it
to the 0-th power.
We've already established
that you start with a 1,
and you multiply it times
that non-zero number 0 times.
So this is always
going to be equal to 1
for non-zero numbers.
So maybe say, hey, maybe
we should extend this
to all numbers, including 0.
So maybe 0 to the 0-th
power should be 1.
So we could make the argument
that 0 to the 0-th power
should be equal to 1.
So you see a conundrum
here, and there's actually
really good cases, and you
can get actually fairly
sophisticated with
your mathematics.
And there's really good
cases for both of these,
for 0 to 0-th being 0, and
0 to the 0-th power being 1.
And so when mathematicians
get into this situation, where
they say, well, there's
good cases for either.
There's not a
completely natural one.
Either of these
definitions would
lead to difficulties
in mathematics.
And so what mathematicians
have decided to do is,
for the most part-- and you'll
find people who will dispute
this; people will say, no, I
like one more than the other--
but for the most part,
this is left undefined.
0 to the 0-th is not defined
by at least just kind
of more conventional
mathematics.
In some use cases,
it might be defined
to be one of these two things.
So 0 to any non-zero number,
you're going to get 0.
Any non-zero number to the 0-th
power, you're going to get 1.
But 0 to the 0, that's a
little bit of a question mark.